[Musique]
hier
une mauvaise
mars le débat crucial de cette journée
pour l'anecdote le gros débat qui a des
lieux juste avant que je prenne la
parole c'était de savoir à quel âge les
Français partiront à la retraite c'était
de savoir à quelle heure serait la pause
déjeuner
7000 tonnes c'est le poids des poubelles
accumulées sur les trottoirs de Paris en
8 jours de mouvement vous avez l'image
imaginez l'odeur et le conflit prend un
virage politique puisque le ministre de
l'Intérieur Gérald Darmanin a demandé à
la mère anidalgo de réquisitionner du
personnel pour débarrasser les rues ce
matin la lettre du préfet a été
transmise à la mairie qui vient de
répondre elle refuse ces réquisitions la
loi prévoit que le préfet peut se
substituer à la ville et ordonner
l'enlèvement des ordures s'il y a un
trouble grave à l'ordre public mais il
se lancerait alors dans un bras de fer
avec les syndicats qui bloquent les
trois incinérateurs parisiens ils ont
voté la poursuite du mouvement jusqu'à
lundi prochain 20 mars les Parisiens
sont assez martyrisés par Madame Hidalgo
moi je vous le dis ça ne peut pas
continuer comme ça c'est un combat pour
que Paris ne soit pas totalement à terre
un peu plus tôt dans la journée
près de 300 militants syndicaux ont jeté
des poubelles sur le siège du parti
présidentiel Renaissance
c'est une action militante
symbolique qui se passe aujourd'hui dans
le débat politique sur les éboueurs ça
pue excusez moi ça pue beaucoup plus que
les ordures qui sont sur le trottoir de
Paris la logique de ces dernières heures
la logique d'un gouvernement qui
n'écoute pas et qui n'entend rien la
logique des LR diviser la logique ou les
conséquences comme vous voulez c'est le
49-3 la logique d'Emmanuel Macron qui
emmerde les non vaccinés qui attaquent
les Gaulois réfractaires qui glorifient
Bruxelles cette 49.3 Emmanuel Macron
brutalisent ce pays comme un enfant
casse ses jouets il y a pas de raison
que ça s'arrête bienvenue aussi
ça me va pas mal
la surpopulation des rongeurs n'est pas
une nouveauté à Paris mais ils n'ont
jamais été aussi nombreux dans la rue le
risque c'est qu'aujourd'hui les rats
sortent à la surface et derrière ils
vont faire leur nid à la surface donc
dans les appartements dans les maisons
dans les immeubles dans les restaurants
donc c'est un problème qui démarre en ce
moment qui risque de durer plusieurs
mois dans le film Adam vous dites très
bien caca je crois que c'est le mot que
vous prononcez le mieux en français caca
[Musique]
mon français c'est génial génial moi
j'ai utilisé
elle a prévu d'aller manifester tout à
l'heure c'est ça Cédric
oui mais elle est maman elle a trois
enfants donc elle a un autre boulot à
faire là il vous reste quoi à faire là
avant de
se lever donc voilà avant d'être
syndicalistes on est aussi maman donc ça
c'est la charge mentale des mamans
désolé pour le bruit BFM qui vient au
petit déjeuner c'est pas cool 8e journée
de manifestation et cette fois la
mobilisation marque le pas un peu
partout en France selon les syndicats un
million 700000 personnes ont défilé dans
les rues contre 3 millions et demi mardi
dernier le constat est plus sévère pour
la police qui a compté 480 000 personnes
plus de deux fois moins que le 7 mars
quoi qu'il se passe aujourd'hui et
demain
quand une loi est un projet de loi est
mauvais la Loire reste mauvaise donc
pour la CGT il y a aucune raison de
baisser la garde c'est pas la manif de
la dernière chance mais c'est la
dernière manifestation d'ampleur avant
le vote au Parlement donc c'est un appel
au parlementaire Éric Naulleau vous êtes
pas la tête
[Musique]
j'attends vraiment mon tour très
tranquillement je regarderai l'émission
depuis chez moi où je suis mieux
installé ou je porte une tenue plus
confortable la majorité travailleront
deux ans de plus mais les femmes qui ont
des carrières hachées travailleront plus
longtemps ceux qui ont commencé tôt
travailleront plus longtemps à un an un
an et trois mois 67 ans et ça ne bouge
pas bonjour ça ne bouge pas ah bah oui
d'accord
et même la première ministre en effet
vous rendez compte on touche pas à l'âge
pivot de 67 ans vous continuerez à
trimer jusqu'à 67 balais
quels
il faut se battre pour se parler je
viens pas pour me battre pour la parole
et non mais alors je vous donne la
parole la
urent
mais on est chez les fous je veux dire
mais vous êtes des des des mais vous
avez tous des je vais vous me faites
peur la 8
pour 6 points elle nous gonfle
il y a tellement de choses qui nous
gonflent
aujourd'hui c'est mon anniversaire
on parle que de trucs cools aujourd'hui
moi quand je voyais je vois votre photo
là je me dis que si on arrive à faire
déplacer la virgule
à 22,8 un pic Mélenchon il reste à 21 à
95 bah alors on a gagné
[Musique]
un robinet et inverse c'est tout ce
qu'il faut se groupe de garçons pour
s'amuser le concept de l'enjeu est
simplissime celui qui fait déborder
l'eau a perdu
déjà plus de 4 millions de spectateurs
tenus en haleine par cette partie
à la fin la main d'un participant
tremble mais la VaR est formelle il y a
faute